مساء الخير فهم خبايا سوق الطاقه واحد من
اهم المداخل اللي فهم التطورات السياسيه
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي العالم
تعالوا ناخذ مثال على اللي انا بقوله
ونقدر نقل الغاز الغاز الطبيعي ومن خلاله
نحاول نفصل ونفهم كثير من التطورات
السياسيه الحادثه في المنطقه خلال
الثلاثين اربعين سنه اللي فاتت
الغاز اللي طبعا البطوله العبر موجود واه
كسلعه قائمه وحيويه لكن اللي جدا علينا
نسبيا ال في السنوات الماضيه هو الغاز
الطبيعي لغايه حوالي ثلاثين خمسه وثلاثين
سنه كان الغاز الطبيعي القليل الاهميه جدا
وكان كثير من شركات البترول تنقب عن
البترول ما بتلاقي بيركز
او بتولع فيه والسبب بساطه انهم ما كانش
عن تكنولوجيا اللي تساعدهم لنقل الغاز من
مواقع الانتاج الى مواقع الاستهلاك
وبالتالي كان قليل الاستخدام جدا لانه ما
كانش فيه وسيله للاستفاده منه وقتها غير
انابيب الغاز
وسيله جيده لكن عندها مشاكل كثيره لانه هي
لابد ان هي تعبر اه اه حدود دول وبالتالي
بتمر باماكن متنازع عليها وبالتالي لازم
في معاهدات وبالتالي الدول لازم تكون
مطمئنه تماما ان الغاز اللي وصل لها دور
يمر على دول صديقه بتحبي مشاكل وبالتالي
كان فيه انابيب الغاز لكن كانت المساله
محدوده التطور الكبير اللي غير العمل ثوره
في سوق الغاز هو ال التكنولوجيا تكنولوجيا
تسهيل الغاز دكتور غازي
في بدايه التسعينات ايه اللي حصل انه
اكتشف العلماء وسيله يمكن بها تسيير الغاز
وبعدين يتم شحنه فيه حاويات اي سلع بال
باخره او بغيرها طبعا في الغالب باخره وفي
المكان اللي يتم تصدير الغاز اليه تكون في
محطه اخرى لتغيير الغاز مره ثانيه يرجعوا
على صوره الاولانيه ويبقى فيه انابيب الى
المصانع والى البيت هذه الثوره
التكنولوجيه ادت الى تغييرات سياسيه كبيره
جدا انا واحد من اهم التطورات السياسيه كل
ما يتعلق بال قطر تاريخ دوله قطر وسياستها
مرتبط ارتباط وثيق جدا بالتطور التكنولوجي
والتطورات الخاصه الغاز يعني على سبيل
المثال
المصدر الرئيسي للثروه قطع هو طبعا الغاز
وتحديدا من حقل الشمال اللي ما هون في
الخليج العربي الحقل تم اكتشافه في
السبعينات لكن للاسباب اللي قلت لحضراتكم
عليها ما كانش فيه قدره كبيره على
الاستفاده منهم
ولغايه بدايه التسعينات يعني غايه حكم
الشيخ خليفه اللي هو جد الامير تميم كانت
السكان تقدر شانها شان باقي دول الخليج
طبعا قطر دوله منتجه للبترول لكن انتقاليه
يعني حتى اللحظه لا انا بكلمك م فيها انت
قطر حوالي ستمائه الف برميل يوميا دون
يعدلوا واحد تقريبا على عشرين من الانتاج
اليومي للسعوديه اللي بدك اكثر من عشره
ونص مليون برميل وبالتالي ما هيش مؤثره
والغير بدايه التسعينات والغاء حكم الشيخ
خليفه قطر شانها شان باقي دول الخليج اللي
تعتمد في مداخلها على البترول مضطره ان
تسير في فلك المملكه العربيه السعوديه
باعتبارها دوله عظمى في مجال البترول لا
تستطيع هذه الدول ان تخرج من عباءتها
باعتبار السعوديه هي اهم محدد الازهار
الطاقه في العالم وظلت على الاقل حتى وان
تاثرت يعني مؤخرا بدخول الولايات المتحده
او روسيا لهم القوتين الاعظم مع السعوديه
لكن ظلت لسنوات طويله هي المحدد الاساس
الاسعار الطاقه البترول في العالم
وبالتالي كل دول الخليج حتى وان كان لديها
خلافات مع السعوديه لم تكن تقرا انت جاهر
بعدها او ان تنهي بعيدا في اعدائها مع
المملكه التطور ما حصل بقى في قطر قطر مع
اكتشاف هذه التكنولوجيا مع بدء استغلال
حقل الشمال اللي بدا ثروات ضخمه جدا على
قطر حولها من دول دوله فقيره نسبيا او
دوله يعني متوسطه الداخلي واحده من اغنى
الدول في العالم الجيل اللي قطر لغايه
2017 حوالي النيه اربعه وثمانين مليار
دولار واربعه وثمانين مليار دولار لما تق
اصبحت يعني لما يوقف على عدد افراد سواء
كان قطر اللي هم اقل من اثنين ونصف مليون
او اثنين وسته من عشره مليون بتتكلم انه
نصيب الفرد يعني الجيل بركابها نصيب الفرد
من الدخل القومي القطري بيتكلم على حوالي
مائه وثمانيه الف وهو الاعلى في العالم
هذه الثروه الضخمه ادت الى انه قطر يكون
عندها سيادي ضخم يستثمر فيه فوائد لانها
دوله ما عندهاش عجز ال
الصندوق او استثمارات الصندوق اللي هو
موجود في ارجاء العالم كلها ب لتنميه
وعشرين مليار دولار
حتى لا اسهم كثيرا في يعني وصف ال او في
تفاصيل الاقتصاد القطري اللي انا عاوز
اقوله انه الغاز اكتشاف الفيز اعطى قطر
ثروه ضخمه
انعكست هذه الثروه على قدرتها على
المناوره السياسيه
وكان ابسط ابسط تلخيص لهذا التغيير انها
قررت انها تتخذ سياسات مستقله ومختلف عن
المملكه تماما النتيجه انه ليس من
المصادفه ان قطر تقريبا الدوله الوحيده
بقول تقريبا لانه سلطنه عمان السياسه
مستقله لكن مش تصادميه لكن قطر هي الدوله
الوحيده التي كانت كانت وما زالت في حاله
صدام مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه على مر
سنوات طويله عمر الثلاثين سنه تقريبا
الماضيه اللي هي عمر تفرط الغاز في قطر
هذه الطفره وهذه الثروه ادت الى انه قطر
اذا حضرتك بتعمل سياسات مختلفه عن
السعوديه تعمل الجزيره تدعم حورات الربيع
العربي سياسات مختلفه تماما عن السعوديه
وعن الامارات ادت الى التوتر اللي احنا
موجودين في وهذا ليس ل هجوما ولا دفاعا عن
قطر لكن تشخيص تتفق او تختلف مع السبب
الاساسي طموح عند كبير الامير الوالد
الشيخ تميم اللي هو الشيخ حمد ثم الامير
تميم لكن المحرك الاساسي هو وجود الغاز
والثروه التي تولدت عن المكان
وبقدر ما ال ال اه في اه حاله صدام او في
حاله تحدي للمملكه لاحظوا في تقارب نسبي
مع ايران ذات في الفتره الاخيره بردو سبب
الخاص لان مصدر ثروه قطر كلها من حقل
الشمال العالم يستهلك من الغاز المسال
حوالي مائتين خمسه وستين مليون طن سنويا
بتنتج قطر منها نصيب قطر منها حوالي
ثلاثين في المائه حوالي العالم حوالي سبعه
وسبعين مليون طن سنويا
والحقت قادر ان ينتخب هذا المعدل لمده
مائه وثلاثين سنه قادمه لكن هذا الحق
للعملاق وتشارك فيها ايران ثلث الحق لقطر
والثلث الاخر لايران هذه المشاركه او هذه
المشاركه في هذا الحقل العملاق بيقدر قطر
على ان تكون دائما على علاقه ان لم تكن
جيده فلا تكون متوتره مع ايران احد اسباب
وعلاقتها الجيده بايران اللي سببها
الرئيسي هو الحق احد الاسباب توتر بينها
وبين باقي الخليج وتحديدا الامارات
والسعوديه
على زي الغاز
غير
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي السياسات وفي
علاقه الدول وبالمناسبه هو احد الاسباب
اللي كان بيسال على اسباب انسحاب قطر من
ال الشهر اعلانها الانسحاب مؤخرا من اوبيك
واللي هيدا فعليا في اول يناير من العام
المقبل هو السبب قطر قالت انه انا مش
محتاجه انا دوله صغيره جدا بنتك حوالي
العالم بان تك حوالي تسعين مليون برميل اه
بترول
مليون برميل في اليوم انا بنتك حوالي
ستمائه الف وبالتالي انا غير مؤثره يعني
انا يعني اه نسبه بسيطه جدا
ومش عاوزه اكون مجرد ديكور في مؤسسه او في
منظمه القاعده الاساسي فيها هو المملكه
اللي هي يعني اه ديني وبالتالي خرجت بس
خرجت اللي في دول ثانيه نصبتها صغيره و
مضطره ان تبقى في اوبيك خرجت لانها مدعومه
ب طموحاتها في تطوير مجال الغاز اللي
اعلنت مؤخرا انه هي عشان تواكب الطلب
وعشان تواكب المنافس الغيها من استراليا
والمنافسه القادمه لها من الولايات
المتحده ومن روسيا اعلنت زيادات قدرتها
على الانتاج خلال الست السنوات القادمه
بنسبه اربعين في المائه عشان توفر للعالم
مائه وعشر مليون طن من استهلاك من الغاز
المسال العالم يدري عليه حوالي ادى مبدئيا
حوالي اثنين واربعين مليار دولار اضافيه
ال بتشوف مثال اخر الغاز اي غير طبعا قبل
مسيب قطر اعتقد ان السعوديه اللي منصرفه
تماما للبترول اكتشفت الغاز مؤخرا بكميات
كبيره في البحر الاحمر في الحدود المقابله
لمصر مصر شعره كمان اللي قدمه السعوديه
اكتشفت الباهيه ممكن يكون عندها خاص في
منطقه البحر الاحمر كانت النتيجه ان
البلدين فكره تقسيم الحدود منهم السعوديه
اكتشفت كميه كبيره فقررت ان هي
بس مائه وخمسين مليار دولار على مدار عشر
سنوات لتطوير حقول الغاز عندها علشان لا
يتصل لا تستاثر قطر وغيرها فقط بس كمان
السعوديه منطق كرئيس للبترول ومن تكامل
الغاز لما مصر والسعوديه عملوا اتفاقيه
ترسيم الحدود على شان الاثنين يستفيدوا من
الثروه القادمه في البحر الاحمر المساله
دي اخذت السودان لانه كاحد التاثيرات
الجانبيه ترسيم الحدود
معناها بالنسبه للسودان السودان انه
السعوديه اقرت ايضا ب اه
حلايب وشلاتين جزء من نصف وهي بتطالب
بحلايب وشلاتين وبت اعتبرها اربعه
وبالتالي هي ممتعه جدا من التقسيم اللي
بيثبت هذا الحق اللي مصر
تداعيات مساله الغاز طبعا انا بتكلم الغاز
ليس محرك وحيد ولكنهم محرك رئيسي اذا
اخدنا مثال ثاني
اخذنا تركيا البلد اللي هي جزء من حياتنا
اليوميه في السياسه او في الاقتصاد وفي
الحال اجتماعيه وحتى في الدراما
التلفزيونيه كثير من تصرفات قطر اه اسف
تركيا
سببوا اه اه ال ال ال الطاقه بصفه عامه
والسوق الغاز بصفه خاصه
يعني مثلا هناك خلافات تاريخيه بين ال اه
التركيه وقبرص جزيره قبرص وكانت نتيجتها
انه تركيه قبل سنه الف وتسعمائه واربعه
وسبعين
وتم تقسيم الجزيره الى شطرين قبرص التركيه
وقبرص اليونانيه قبل السريون ان يعترف بها
العالم كله قبرص التركيه لا يعترف به الا
التركيه هذه القصه يقول شرحها مش موضوعنا
لكن احد اسباب استمرار التوتر الى اللحظه
القدره او زياده التوتر هو اكتشاف الخير
بكميات ضخمه في شرق البحر المتوسط تركيا
لكل الدول الواقع على حضر البحر المتوسط
كانت تامل ان يكون لها نصيب في هذه الثروه
خصوصا انها فقيره في اه مجال الغاز يعني
بكثير من ان تفي حدودها بس حدود المياه
بتاعها محدود والسبب انه وفقا للقانون ان
الدول
تقاسم الثروات بين حدود الدول اللي هي
متقبله يعني مثلا المصري لما تيجي اسم
حدودهم تاثيرها مع مين مع قبرص ولا مع
تركيا واقع الامر الى قبرص الجزيره
الصغيره عندها مجموعه صغيره جدا صخريه
الايه لا يسكن فيها احد لكن لها جزء من
اراضي قبرص النتيجه انه ترقيه الدوله
الكبيره لا تستطيع ان تقاسم الثروه اللي
موجوده في البحر المتوسط لا مع اسرائيل
ولا مع مصر ولا مع مستقبلا مع اي دوله
اخرى وذكرت سوريا ولبنان ببساطه لانه
الجزر القبرصيه تجعل مصر وتجعل اسرائيل
تقسم حدودها مع قبرص وليس تركيا التي
حددتها الجزر الصغير القوصي هذا سبب اضافه
للتوتر معقول
والسبب اضافه للتوتر مع مصر لانه مصر كانت
حريصه جدا انها تعتزم علاقاتها بقبرص
مؤخرا بسبب اكتشاف الغاز لكم ان تعلم ان
مصر عملت مع قبرص اكثر من عشرين اتفاقيه
اطاريه في ثلاث سنين اتفقت كلها تتعلق
بالاستفاده من الثروه القادمه مين ازاي
نستفيد من الثروه المشتركه لانه الواضح
انه حضور وحق لافراد اللي اكتشف في قبرص
مصدر هم خزان واحد وهما بين
من بعد انسحاب ازاي
الحقل اذا كانت مشترك
العمل مع بعض النساء الحفر مع بعض من يحرص
من يوفر الحراسه وهكذا تتغير كبيره ارض
مصر ال قبرص ويدعم ويبعد مصر تركيا ستبقى
في ال على الواجهه اللي فيه خلافات سياسيه
هو فيه غضب من مصر على تركيا ومن التركيه
على مصر لكن الواقع ان احد الاسباب
الرئيسيه وابار الغاز
اذا اخدنا مثال ثالث علي زاي الغاز بغير
سياسات الشرق الاوسط ناخذ مثال زي اه
لبنان واسرائيل لبنان واسرائيل بينهم
خلافات كثيره لكن احد الاسباب الرئيسه
للخلاف والتي قد تؤدي الى اه مواجهه
عسكريه او صدام عسكري قريب هو ما تقوله
لبنان من اتهام لبنان لاسرائيل بانها تسطو
على حقولها او حقها في المائه الاقتصاديه
للبنان وبدات في عمليات الحفر والاستكشاف
ولبنان بتقول ان جزء من هذه الابار يعود
الى وليس الى اسرائيل واحد من الاسباب لو
كنت حضرتكم بتابعوا الاخبار في الفتره
الاخيره احنا خلال الشهر الماضي فوجئنا
بانه تحترق برس تحذيرا شديدا من ان تقوم
باستضافه اي قواعد عسكريه امريكيه في
الكثيره
واضطرت قبرص تحت التهديد التركي ان تي ان
تنفي الفكره علاقات لي تنزعج اه روسيا من
قبل ستستضيف قواعد عسكريه من قاله
العسكريه في كل مكان لسببين واحد عسكري
اذا وضعت قرب قاعده عسكريه امريكيه عندها
معنا هكذا ان القاعده القاعدتين ال
عسكريتين الروسيتين في سوريا في درس وسواح
مين ها تكون محاصره ما بين القواعد
الامريكيه اللي موجوده في سوريا والقاعده
العسكريه الجديده التي تعتزم قبرص في
استضافتها وهذا يعني حصار الروس لكن السبب
التالي المتعلق بالغاز
الروس لديهم طموح ان يكونوا جزءا من هذه
المشاريع الضخمه الموجوده في شرق المتوسط
ولا يرغب في وجود قاعده عسكريه لدور
معاديه لها وهم الامريكان اعطيكم مثال
اخير على ان الغاز الدائره التوترات
وتغيير في الخريطه بس خارج المنطقه بس
استاذنكم علشان نوع من ال استدراك ان احد
اسباب التوتر ايضا بالنصر وقطر ليس فقط
مساله الاخوان المسلمين ولا قناه الجزيره
ولكن ايضا الغاز يعني اكتشاف الغاز بكميات
كبيره في مصر معناها تاثير على سوق ال ال
السوق الخاصه بقطر طبعا لانه خسر الزبون
لكن كمان فيه سبب ثانيه انه قطر كانت تطمح
من سنوات طويله
انهى خط انابيب من عندها الى ميناء يا
اللي موجود في اسرائيل على البحر المتوسط
في وبالتالي هي تقدر تصدر الغاز المسال
يكون افضل بكثير جدا ان هي تصدر عن طريق
قناه السويس او عن طريق راس الرجاء الصالح
وبالتالي تنافس الجزائر في اللي هي
المصدر الرئيسي حتى هذه اللحظه الى اوروبا
في منطقه الشرق المتوسط هذه الخطوه فشلت
تعثرت الاول في البدايه ثم فشلت الان لان
مع اكتشاف الغاز المصري اسرائيل لم تعد
ترى ان هذه الخطوه الضروريه اللي هو ممكن
تحصل على الغاز من مصر وبالتالي يفسر لنا
التقارب المصري الاسرائيلي في الفتره
الاخيره ويفسر لنا التقارب التركي الاسف
الاردني المصري لانه اردني سوف تعود مره
اخرى الاعتماد على هذا المصري مثال اخير
قبل ان اختم عشان تعرفوا على الخريطه
الدوليه
في توتر شديد ما بين اوكرانيا والروس له
اسباب كثيره جدا جدا جدا لكن احد هذه
الاسباب انه كان اه اه اوكرانيا سعيده ب
اللي هي ال اه انابيب الغاز الروسيه اللي
بيتغذى معظم اوروبا توفر لها النصيب
الاكبر من الطاقه اصبحت انابيب الغاز بين
عملاقين بيروحوا الى المانيا ومن المانيا
بروح ولا باقي دول اوروبا ثمان
روسيا الى تركيا اوروبا لا يعني ان محابس
الغاز لم تعد تصل الى اوكرانيا معناه ان
في مداخيل كثيره فقدتها معنا هنا فقدت
كثير كثير من الاهميه وبالتالي احد اسباب
التوتر والغضب الاوكراني يتعلق ايضا
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]